remember 5 to 10 years ago when everyone
used to play mobile games you had
cult-like friend groups that swore by
Clash of Clans or Clash Royale or
Geometry Dash they would spend all of
their allowed iPad time or iPod time on
these games and that's all they would
talk about at school and at Hangouts and
basically anywhere else they met up
don't ask me how I know and those were
just the Tier 1 games you also had a
slew of tier 2 games that were sometimes
even more popular these games didn't
have as dedicated fan bases though they
were more of something that you would
play on the bus or at lunch or whenever
you had a bit of free time I'm talking
about games like tempo run Subway
Surfers Flappy Bird crossy Road 2048
Angry Birds and so much more that I
can't even remember because those days
are unfortunately long gone at first it
seemed like it was just these OG games
that were dying out as they had simply
run their course but the more time that
passed the more it became clear that
mobile games in general were falling out
of favor of course we've seen newer
games like Among Us and Fall Guys clones
have their 5 Seconds Of Fame but none of
these have had the same sticking power
as the OG games here's how the interest
graph looks like for Among Us for
example as you can see it was just one
massive Spike for perspective here's how
the interest graph for Clash of Clans
looks like it's much more of a mountain
of interest that lasted multiple years
than just a singular Spike that lasted
months now I do want to note that
Geometry Dash has been making a comeback
out of nowhere which I think is largely
due to extremely highquality videos made
by people like samifying and math genius
that have reminded millions of OG
players just how fun this game was but
aside from this one exception that we
don't even know how long will last
Mobile gaming is very much a shell of
its former self which is extremely
confusing given that smartphones have
only become become even more popular
throughout all of this so why does no
one want to play mobile games
[Music]
anymore to answer why no one plays
mobile games anymore we first have to
take a look back at what made mobile
games so popular in the first place
which I think can be boiled down to
three reasons starting with the network
effect none of the games that I played
as a kid were something that I found on
my own on YouTube or the app store or
something all of the games that I played
as a kid were games that people around
me played people at school people on the
bus people at Hangouts and of course a
few dads who tried to be cool nowadays
though I never see anyone around me
playing mobile games my only exposure to
Mobile gaming is through ads from games
like raid Shadow Legends which is
obviously not as effective this isn't to
say that the network effect ever changed
though the number one reason that people
download apps today is still because of
people around them but what did change
was the type of app that benefited from
a network effect nowadays it's much more
common for a social media app or TV show
to benefit from the network effect than
a mobile game and that brings us into
reason number two which is that mobile
games used to have larger than game
goals take Clash of Clans for example
progressing in the game wasn't just
about personal growth or something it
was much more competitive you wanted to
be the first guy to get to town hall 10
or 3,000 trophies or beat Hexagon forest
in your friend group and that was just
on a micro scale the most successful
games also had larger macro goals you
wanted your friend group to beat a rival
friend group in a clan war or your clan
to have more Champion League players or
whatever else the case may be zooming
out even more you wanted your favorite
YouTuber to be the one that won these
massive YouTuber Clash of Clans and
Clash Royale tournaments this
competitive Spirit probably doesn't seem
like that b big of a deal but it makes
all the difference why you ask well
because no game is always 100% fun with
any game there's high points and low
points but for these games with larger
than game goals you didn't just quit
when things got a bit slow or boring
because you still had larger than game
goals you still had to beat that rival
Clan you still had to get to the
legendary League you still had to beat
Theory of Everything too these macro
goals gave these games an insane amount
of sticking power it wasn't until entire
communities got bored of a game and its
overarching goals that it would actually
die I'm talking about dedicated YouTube
channels that cover these games people
like Chief Pat galadon malt clash with
Ash orang juice BJ can diive flammy and
so many more not only did these channels
help these games grow in popularity but
more importantly they helped them stay
relevant through the ups and downs this
sort of community is what has kept games
like Minecraft C so popular over the
years but a lot of these channels
nowadays don't even cover mobile gaming
anymore or even post for that matter and
we have yet to see a new wave of
YouTubers take their place for example
there is no such Community for Among Us
or fall guys or some other new mobile
game combine this lack of community with
very little Network effect and no larger
than game goals and it's no wonder why
these games have fallen out of
popularity but all of that only tells
half the story which brings us into the
developer side of
[Music]
things one of the main reasons that
Mobile gaming became so popular in the
early 2010 is because they were free to
play as long as you had a smartphone or
tablet anyone could download a mobile
game and start playing this isn't to say
that developers didn't make any money
though if your game was super popular
and you had super enticing in- game
purchases like supercell you could also
become super rich but somewhere along
the line monetization became more
important than the user experience and
the enjoyability of the game itself at
first this was just something that
manifested in tier 2 games you know
those airplane mode games like subway
surfers that filled up time initially
the economics of these games were pretty
simple you usually had a light version
of the game and a full version of the
game the light version of the game was
usually free and came with fewer levels
and maybe some ads here and there the
ads weren't all that serious though as
developers weren't really trying to make
money off of ads their number one goal
with the light version was to convince
people that the game was actually fun
and worth spending a dollar on to get
the full version and the full version is
where they actually made their money but
all of this changed with the rise of
free-to-play tier one games like Clash
of Clans Clash Royale pubg fortnite
mobile and so on there was like a direct
inverse correl relation between the
popularity of these games and people's
willingness to pay for mobile games if
something as built out as Clash of Clans
could be free why did they have to pay
for these stupid tier 2 games and all of
a sudden trying to convince free users
to pay for the full version of the game
became magnitudes harder these
developers had to Pivot and figure out a
way to monetize free users and the
easiest way to do that is to just show a
bunch of ads and this is what has led to
the App Store big filled with thousands
of games that are actually somewhat fun
but completely unenjoyable because you
see an ad every 30 seconds as such one
of the main reasons that mobile gaming
has plummeted is because of corporate
efforts to monetize and restrict these
games in this same manner big banks have
long restricted our savings account
interest rates of course the federal
fund rate itself was low but if we're
being honest the 0.1 or 0.25% rat that
Banks like Chase and Wells Fargo offered
were just downright disrespectful the
only reason they kept it so low was
because they knew that we would keep our
money with them anyway because of the
stability and security they offered we
wanted to challenge this notion and
that's why we created our own investing
platform Silo instead of betting on the
stability of Chase or Wells Fargo with
Silo you can bet on the stability of the
US federal government itself you see
just like all of us the US federal
government also needs to sometimes
borrow money and if you're willing to
write a check to the US government well
they'll currently pay you back with over
5% interest while the rest of us were
earning 0% interest at Chase this is
where all of the biggest corporations
and investors were storing all of their
cash if you'd also like to take
advantage of treasuries and bonds with
the protection of $500,000 in sipc
insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
Insurance please consider consider
checking out Silo in the description
below but anyway it wasn't just tier 2
games that made this transition Tier 1
games would also make this transition
Tier 1 games didn't play their games
with a bunch of ads but what they did do
was make the game worse and worse for
free players now of course these games
were always easier to progress in if you
spent money but it was also realistic
for a free player to advance and do well
in the game at least originally but in
the second half of the 2010s this would
all change as these games essentially
became paid to win Clash of Clans for
example currently costs
$143,000 to max out and a recent Clash
Royale update increased the cost to max
out by over
$114,000 by itself back in the day it
didn't cost that much to max out the
entirety of Clash of Clans and the worst
part is that the stuff that cost the
most money doesn't actually add anything
to the gameplay or enjoyability it Act
actually has to do with upgrading walls
or getting cards from Level 14 to level
15 things that add no value to the game
other than just making these companies
more money these companies probably
thought that they were doing the right
thing for the company as Revenue
continued to go up but they were also
simultaneously alienating free players
who over time wanted nothing to do with
mobile
gaming
we've clearly seen massive changes
within the mobile gaming space both on
the community side and on the developer
side much of which has been to the
detriment of mobile gaming as a whole
but while these shifts explain a lot I
think there's actually an X Factor that
we have yet to consider which is
Shifting demographics I would bet that
most of you guys watching this video are
likely in your early to late 20s and are
reminiscing about the good old days of
mobile gaming back in middle school and
high school school and that's not
surprising given that the primary
demographic that plays mobile games are
teenagers and that's why it's important
to consider just how different modern
teenagers are compared to 10 years ago
back in the day smartphones were just
starting to gain steam meaning that most
of us had to beg our parents for a
smartphone and when we finally did get a
smartphone it came with a bunch of
caveats we may have only had a gigabyte
of data our phones may have had parental
controls enabled and maybe we weren't
allowed to use social media apps like
Instagram and Snapchat I remember one of
my elementary school friends his parents
would turn off the Wi-Fi at like 8 or 9
every day because there was simply no
need for internet at night so if he
wanted to use his phone after 8 or 9 all
he could do was play offline games like
Geometry Dash not everyone had the same
restrictions but the restrictions were
widespread enough that one of the only
things that everyone could do with their
phones together was play familyfriendly
mobile games but a lot has changed since
then nowadays smartphones have become a
necessity and if you're over the age of
12 you probably have a smartphone
parents have also become a lot less
strict when it comes to phone usage not
only do modern kids have less strict
screen time but they also have
unrestricted access to the internet and
social media this isn't to say that
parents have become more irresponsible
per se but simply that there is no other
choice I mean like what are you going to
do just shelter your kids from the
internet till they're 18 first of all
that's just a massive disadvantage in
the Modern Age and second of all it's
not even possible as kids are more Tex
saavy than ever and know how to bypass
any and every restriction as such the
focus has shifted from blocking what
teenagers have access to to teaching
them how to be safe and responsible on
the internet in other words the average
teenager today has access to social
media platforms like Tik Tok YouTube
Instagram and Snapchat at and that's
where they spend all of their time AKA
The Casual teenage Mobile gaming Market
the one's largest market for these games
has completely disappeared and the
teenagers that are still interested in
playing games usually just have a
console or PC for that leaving modern
mobile games in no man's land this is
really quite a shame because playing
these games were some of my best
childhood memories but the reality is
that the mobile landscape has massively
shifted for gamers developers and Casual
smartphone users and that's why no one
plays mobile games anymore if you would
like to help Silo not end up like that
please consider checking out the link in
the description below but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one